more flour i'm going rogue it smells
like pizza is this poison if i just eat
it like this when do you put the yeast
in i wonder way long ago
[Music]
today we're in the tasty kitchen where
the try guys will try their hand at
making bread
but there's a catch they will not be
getting a recipe or any instructions how
to do it they would just have to go by
their own initiative and the ingredients
they have chosen no no and no no the
bakers will then be judged by our panel
alexis bosnick from buzzfeed's own tasty
kitchen hannah hart from her show i
heart food on the food network and that
call from la's famous clark street
bakery bread is very very simple on
paper you get the flour and by adding
water to it it makes gluten which is
able to trap gas we use the salt just to
give bread flavor without it be bland
and we use the yeast to to make the gas
in bread and that's why bread is
inflated and is nice and fluffy this is
an extremely easy thing to mess up
especially if you don't have you know a
lot of practice doing it
bread bread is one of those things that
everybody's eating
but how do you make bread i don't bake i
don't cook anything i used to be a
chemist so i know that baking is a very
precise science and like math i can look
at a problem and know it's algebra but
i'm not gonna know what the answer is
we're just gonna [ __ ] wing it you
guys i think i'm gonna win this today i
think for once keith is like the leader
uh because i think i know what i'm doing
ready guys on your mark get set and try
and bake to get started our bakers must
first select their ingredients from the
tasty pantry and i hope they choose
wisely liquid bread
oh boy this is overwhelming there's a
lot of stuff i would suggest to start
with a loaf of just flour water salt and
yeast you know it's sort of like the
benchmark it's like do this before you
move on to adding other ingredients to
it do you guys know where gluten is i
think you just need salt yeast and flour
so is there anything else i should get
sugar
we got honey today i'm gonna make a
white bread you know white bread's a lot
like me plain
not super healthy generally likeable
time
i love black roasted sesame seeds i love
alcohol i love spice those two things
represent me i'm gonna try to find a way
to fold it into bread i don't know if
either belonged there but i'm gonna make
it happen my ancestors made the mistake
of forgetting yeast in their bread i am
not going to follow in their footsteps
boom three things of yeast my approach
is just gonna be i'm just gonna grab as
much [ __ ] as possible and hope that
something happens i don't want to create
poison
how many eggs do i need [ __ ] it i'll
take all of them oh cinnamon
oh my god yes
in my family me and my dad were the only
two people that liked cinnamon raisin
bread so it's a very special memory for
me and i'm going to try and recreate the
cinnamon raisin bread that we bought at
the store
ready set
bake
okay
what are we grabbing what a bowl i need
a bowl need a big bowl a small bowl
so first thing you want to do when
you're making bread is to mix together
your ingredients first ingredient the
bread bread crumbs time to bake
nobody i have this sugar from japan i
didn't grab sugar i grabbed honey which
is essentially
sugar that's been vomited out of a bee's
mouth my bread is going to be a honey
white bread and i'm going to give it an
egg wash on top so it looks extra
special cayenne
are you starting with spices is that i'm
just mixing them together
my bread is going to be the drunken 12
spice loaf it has an entire pack of ipa
beer and lots of spice so what's your
game plan ned uh first i'm going to make
a cinnamon and sugar mixture and set it
aside uh it's gonna give it some color
some swirls and some sweetness today i'm
making a cinnamon raisin bread it
reminds me of growing up eating toast
um i bought i got three different types
of
flour uh so i'm just gonna go with this
one because it sounds the fanciest
buckwheat flour get my buckwheat on
today i am baking a buckwheat loaf
including some of my favorite things
like nutella gummy bears and breadcrumbs
i am starting with uh yeast so what is
yeast
this is the stuff that gives women
infections is this different yeast and
so one of these yeast packets is 14
grams just a little bit of that
there we go it's all the yeast you need
yeast is going in baby oh my god as
everyone knows all chemical reactions
get accelerated by agitation so i'm
going to stir my yeast
you know yeast is in beer don't you well
if eugene's putting more yeast then i
want more yeast i'm supposed to put some
amount of this water into this bowl and
then add some amount of sugar in as well
because the sugar activates the yeast
you don't need to activate the yeast if
it's dried like this you can just add it
straight in with the dry ingredients
mix it add the water it'll do its thing
we'll put in the flour pour it off get
in there get in there
all about the ratios next we'll go with
20 grams of salt
mazel tov this is what they do in the
cooking show so let's do it like that so
i'm just going to put in a tablespoon
and now we can add our water make a nice
soft dough
you should use water
here now you just want to mix it until
all of the water's been absorbed and
it's homogenized so there's no pieces of
dry flour remaining and there's no no
clumps looks like you're doing very well
actually i have watched a lot of cooking
shows oh they roll the dough into a
little ball does egg go and bread cause
i'm putting it in there why is mine look
like doo-doo did i need to get some more
flour in there because that's more like
um
my pies than anything else maybe real
flour now i don't want to open a new
flour or eugene i'm going to borrow some
flour buddy there's one thing this dough
needs and it's a little more love
you want to make sure that you need your
bread enough the way to tell whether you
need it enough is it'll change from this
sort of like putty to kind of holding
its own shape a little bit more it'll
look smooth it'll look shiny this feels
a lot like i'm massaging a really
squishy butt it's taking me forever to
[ __ ] knead this okay i need this
y'all this is coming together how is
yours that color i don't know
why is that why so from that point on
you want to be kind of hands off you
don't want to be too rough with it i
need this baby because everything you do
to it will knock gas out of it and make
it denser and harder to bake through
beer volcano
more look the more solid stuff i put in
here the better shot i got i did find a
beer bottle cap in it before but i took
it out at this point you're just shaping
it so that it looks like a loaf of bread
you want to make sure there's not too
much flour just enough otherwise it
prevents the dough from sticking to
itself i've got my bread all rolled up
with cinnamon and sugar and raisins
right now you know it looks like it
looks like one of those airplane pillows
this is my lump it's a little bit of
buckwheat uh some nutella in there
because you know everyone loves nutella
threw in some fruity pebs for the
nostalgia factor here's my bread nice
and ready i hate that eugene's dough
looks pretty okay right now after you've
shaped it then it proofs and what i like
to do at this point is to stick it in
the fridge overnight it'll rise really
slow at a cool temperature the next
morning when you come back to it you'll
see it's doubled in volume
and it's ready to be baked so it's been
quite a day for our bakers and now
they're ready to put their dough aside
to proof overnight oh i hope they don't
[ __ ] it up
[Music]
it's day two of this exciting baking
challenge everyone's waiting to see have
their breads risen
my yeast was foaming so hopefully things
worked out okay i'm just worried it's
gonna be too big really i think no
matter what happens we're all impressed
you know talk about the journey not the
destination it was already rising pretty
well by the end of yesterday so i i have
good hopes for it i think i did pretty
poorly yesterday might have been one of
my worst performances in shy guy's
history
let's see
okay let's see it
whoa oh no
no that's good it's uh i didn't expect
it to become flat like a soup oh my god
it went from an airline pillow to a butt
pad
hey it rose a little bit it looks like a
stale turd
holy
[ __ ]
still smells like beer this looks crazy
this is awful it's a monster and
hopefully i can bake it
[Music]
okay so let's talk about how to bake it
so i'm gonna try and make a cinnamon
bundt cake
bread cake is really just a type of
bread one of the most beautiful things
you can do with bread is a signature
something that lets everybody know that
it's your bread and not anyone else's
bread so i'm going to split it with a k
for keith how does he know so much about
bread i'm just going to throw butter on
it yeah now we got a real buttery dough
oh it's squirting to complete my
bread i'm going to give it a nice crust
of pretzels and chocolate
did nothing
[Music]
i can't even break a pretzel right i'm
gonna make a braid and there's one thing
i know to do with two sisters is braid i
really respect what's happening on this
side of the room but we're getting a
little avant-garde with it you know
we're mixing it up
[Music]
yes queen yes
you bake it for about 40 minutes at 475
degrees i'm doing 350 degrees 40 minutes
i don't know i'm just gonna say 30
minutes i wanted to pre-heat mine at 375
as well wow because of a frozen food i
would say that if i'm doing it that's
maybe a sign you shouldn't do it i'm
gonna do a little egg wash on it so that
it can look sexier oh that's not washing
the way i want it to you add some water
in there too or just not no just egg
should it be water too a little bit well
i can see that there's some bubbling
happening down there smells good why is
it bubbling well that's a cake pan for
soda i gotta stand out in this
competition
oh i think you will
it looks like a cottage loaf
oh okay that sounds fancy i'll die i
think i'm good yeah i'm gonna take it
out all right there you go then what
you're left with is something like this
a loaf of bread that's got a nice color
to it nice and even shape nice volume
this is pretty amazing i can't believe
it i'm gonna [ __ ] win that's bread
the egg wash definitely remained just
egg on top of bread it certainly smells
like eggs but otherwise i think it's
good i assume you put butter on
everything because butter is delicious
[Music]
it's bread
sesame seeds
welcome to the final judging when we
will find out who is the top baker we'll
be judging on three categories
presentation
taste and is it bread
ned will you please present your bread
judges i present to you ned's cinnamon
raisin is that a bundt cake it is a
bundt uh pan that was used to make the
bread yes
the bread
it smells pretty sweet and it's got a
nice a nice heft to it thank you
well you got the you got the swirl oh
wow but um the inside's gorgeous yes
let's see how it tastes maybe
oh man
i think that's about sums up what i
think of the taste
where is the bitterness coming from give
it a try
need some milk right about now right i
think it's a good uh good first try for
sure uh but definitely you can use a
little bit more sugar and salt next time
just to get the the flavor it's a little
bit bland
so judges my question now is is it bread
it is bread like but there's so much
more it wants to be
the more i eat it the more i'm into it
that is called stockholm syndrome
here it comes
oh is that an egg wash just initially
the the first scent i'm getting off of
it is the yolk it really smells like egg
presentation wise i think this looks
like it could be bread yeah i think
without the egg wash it would look just
like a
a really nice attempt of bread yup i
think i [ __ ] it up right at the end
there
give it a shot
oh my god
it's got zero flavor
well it's gotta have some flavor you're
really reacting and it's under-baked
let's see if it bounces
you'd think that it would have
so judges
is it bread
this is definitely bread we can give it
that we can give it that
all right judges wow oh it's beautiful
oh my god thank you um
this is eugene's drunken spice loaf were
you drunk when you made it i was the
color it's good the color is better the
braid is beautifully done ready and
bread
oh
wow
look at this it looks really good this
feels like bread
oh wow
that's great
i would almost swallow this
i will
really yes this is my my slice is good i
just feel like it's like
like old beer
it is three bottles of beer you might
have gotten a lot of star nice in your
slice i i didn't know how it was
proportioned is this your first time
making bread
yeah it's my first time saying not not a
bad job at all
actually slightly impressive
[Music]
so the final question is is it bread
absolutely am i still drunk because i
wasn't expecting these answers
okay zach please present your bread
judges today we've seen where bread has
been i'm going to show you where bread
is going if you will an introduction i
present my take
on the buckwheat bread
the buck sweet bread
what forest floor did you pick this up
off of you're telling me that if you
walked into like an organic food
restaurant and you saw that you would be
like yeah i'm intrigued you know it
looks rustic thank you thank you
i don't want to eat it
because you just want to look at it all
day cause it's so beautiful i get it
we're just gonna
does it look like
there's bread sprinkles in here oh i
like that it just it falls it's a
crumble loaf did i not mention that
i'm real confident in this one i can't
it's funny because i actually can't seem
to pick it up come on zach from one zack
to another no
zach oh my god
all right we lost zach that's fine
there's only room for one second here
got my girls no come on
that is the worst
food i've ever tried in my life wow
i didn't know i would be getting a
superlative today that's amazing oh my
god
it's truly terrible thank you
i actually i'm covered in chills i
swallowed like at least 10 of that
that's not the goal you could not pay me
to eat this is it bread
this is not bread at all right because
it's it's next level uh no this is not
bread chefs thank you you know i can
leave this
no more you want you should burn it so
judges
what do you think on the bright side we
know which is the worst oh yeah ned's
was really beautiful true and if he had
been going for
bundt cake yes he would have really
nailed it and if he had used sugar
keith's
it looked like a big pterodactyl egg to
me pete's
i liked a little because i like eggs
eugene's it was very impressive that
the braid yeah that braid that he does
the piece you had was
more edible i was thinking about
swallowing yep john i believe we're in
agreement
okay let's call them back in
[Music]
so welcome back bakers the judges have
given us their results
are you ready
fourth
is that well the challenge was to make
bread and um you did not
and third we have
ned
it looked nice when it came out it
looked really nice now really good job
really nice
so and second
we have keith
the dinosaur egg you really have a
future in almost sort of making bread
and now for the big finale i wonder who
it could be please to announce
eugene eugene
congratulations hey thank you i've been
asking for hugs all day
i really think it was the the coloring
and the distribution that that's what
edged everybody out you know you
actually had something that was kind of
like a crust it's not good
no no let's not let's not get confused
here it's not good it's not good but
it's the best out of the others
i think we learn how to accidentally
make bread this has inspired me to try
cooking more than i do now can't help
but say i'm incredibly discouraged by
the outcome of today's video i tried so
hard to engineer a video that couldn't
end the same way all videos end
sometimes you take risks and like eugene
it pays off
other times those risks do not pay off i
want to try and bake bread with a recipe
next time i feel like i could have
really nailed this i just had a couple
of simple instructions eugene did taste
better okay i'll admit it that's what
i'm upset about his bread was better i'm
not mad because i think that his wasn't
better and i should have won he should
have won i'm mad that i wanted to win
more and i didn't
i'm disappointed in myself
and i've been externalizing all my
angers on eugene or other people but i'm
mad at my own shortcomings
shouldn't put the egg on top
[Music]